it's now my honor to introduce our
commencement day speaker
the founder of the online education
phenomenon known as the Khan Academy Sal
Khan
Sal earned three degrees from MIT a
bachelor's in mathematics as well as a
bachelor's and master's degree in
electrical engineering and computer
science
rounding out his education with an MBA
from Harvard
Sal began his career as a hedge fund
analyst within a few years however he
discovered quite by accident what has
become his calling
through preparing video tutorials to
help his young cousin learn math
he came to understand both his own gifts
as a teacher and a great gift that he
could give to the World by creating an
online library of thousands of free
bite-sized videos that would shed light
on any topic he chose from geometry to
the GDP
today the Khan Academy channel on your
YouTube has more than 330 000
subscribers and has delivered more than
156 million lessons and has for millions
of students replaced bafflement with
understanding
for launching this revolutionary
experiment in online learning in the
year 2012 Time magazine named Sal Ken as
one of the hundred most influential
people on the planet
this is not the first time that Sal has
spoken from the commencement stage here
in Killian Court
because he also served as president of
his class
in 1998 addressing his fellow graduates
Sal said and I quote it is no
exaggeration to say that we will change
the world end quote having checked this
assignment off his to-do list he joins
us here today ladies and gentlemen
salkon
thank you
no this this is really a a surreal uh a
deep honor to be here for for a whole
set of reasons and as was introduced
obviously MIT has played a a big role in
my own life but I think a much deeper
role than than many of y'all might
appreciate uh you some of you might
remember in the late 90s kind of when
the first internet boom was happening
there was a lot of talk about about
online education and most of the
conversation back then about online
education actually not too different
than now was around how to profit off of
it how to make money off of it or some
institutions were thinking about how to
defend against it or or at least kind of
sit on the sidelines and see how
everything played out and and all of a
sudden MIT jumped into the mix 2001
and announced MIT open courseware that
it was going to take knowledge and
resources that used to be behind the the
walls of elite institutions and not
charge for them but but give them away
for free to the world and instead of
saying how can we profit off of this MIT
said well there are some things that are
higher than that there are some things
that if we could if we could Empower an
unlimited number of people for for all
of time maybe that's something that we
would be willing to spend resources on
and when that happened you know I was I
was just a uh a couple years out of
college working at a tech company in San
Francisco I had no idea that my own
career Adventure would lead to to what
I'm doing now but when I read that press
release
I had never been so inspired I had never
felt so proud to come from from this
community
and frankly a couple of years later when
the videos that I had made for my
cousins it became clear that people who
who were not my cousins started watching
there there was talk of well this could
be a business I was in Silicon Valley
this is what it was all about I worked
for a hedge fund a very uh for-profit
organization
and but it was the memory of how I felt
the first time I read that press release
about open courser and what open
courseware had become that really gave
me the the frankly the clarity to
understand what Khan Academy could be
that it could be this institution that
could reach everyone that should
transcend ideas of profits and and
businesses and I say this not just to
show the connection that it had for Khan
Academy but there's a there's kind of a
meta level idea here that these days you
hear a lot of universities and
institutions talk about teaching ethics
teaching morality instilling that when
they'll take classes on it and tell you
to read about it
but MIT actually did it MIT actually
lived by its actions it actually put it
actually put principle over profit and
it's continuing to do it now with mitx
now edx in in concert with Harvard it's
continuing to push the envelope and I'm
just I'm just in awe of it feels like
we're living in a science fiction book
of what might happen in in education in
in the next few years
but my connections to MIT go even deeper
than that
obviously I went here but my wife also
graduated from MIT class of 2001. the
president of Khan Academy and Chief
Operating Officer he was my roommate
freshman year at next house
that's room 343 for the two or three of
you who might have shared that room at
some point
the one of our board members went to MIT
his wife went to MIT
and so we and that's I'm just starting
that's that's just a small sample of all
of the the people we know at MIT but
maybe even more surprisingly the fact
that of the people we know from MIT now
90 of them are married to each other
and anytime you have this type of love
come from one place I think one should
introspect as romantic as the infinite
Corridor may be
and uh you know I I've seen such extreme
coupling here that I've I've often
suspected that this whole place might
just be a front for a some type of
darpa-funded breeding project
someone knows what's going on up here
but there are there are simpler
explanations and I think the most
obvious one uh and at least the most
clear to me is that the admissions
office here at both the undergraduate
and graduate level seems to have a
somewhat unhealthy bias for only
admitting extremely attractive people
you're welcome
I thought that would go over well
the uh but I think it goes even deeper
than that
as long as I can remember to anyone who
who listened to me I've told people that
MIT is the closest thing on this planet
Earth to Hogwarts
to to Harry Potter's Wizarding School
that the the the ideas and the research
and the science that percolates Behind
These Walls that's the closest thing to
Magic in the real world and frankly to
people outside of this campus looks like
magic
The Faculty we have here these are the
leading wizards of our time
the Dumbledore's
the dumbledores and mcgonagalls and I
guess president hockfield you would be
McGonagall
the uh
the the the Halls here they have secret
passages and tunnels and around every
corner they're strange and bizarre
magical objects and creatures some of
whom may finish their thesis this decade
maybe a few in the audience
the the when we're in Killian court it's
almost a shrine when you look at the
names around us you see Newton and
Darwin and and Galileo and and and and
and Archimedes and these are the the
great wizards of history and and they
remind us that we have inherited uh an
ancient tradition an ancient art one
that for much of history and even now
today to some degree has always been
sometimes vilified or suppressed by
forces of ignorance but despite that has
always shown through and has been at
least in my mind the prime cause of of
human advancement
the people who come here the students
who come here you
there are these people all these young
people all over the world from every
Walk of Life who are all off the charts
in some special way for this kind of
magic that goes on here and some come
from affluent Rich educated families
because some some of you come from poor
families where you're the first to get a
college degree some come from
environments where their gifts were
really celebrated some come from
environments where frankly most of their
life that they had to hide their their
passions their gifts for for fear of
looking different
but they come here
suspecting that this might be a place
where they can spread their wings where
they can where they can explore the
world they can finally look with Clarity
at the mysteries of the universe the
magic of everything that surrounds us
and MIT I think delivers on that it
opens our minds to what's possible and
and and even more uniquely it pushes us
and I and I do believe that MIT pushes
us harder than probably any other
institution in the world
but when you do that you take someone to
another level you take them truly to
recognize what they're capable of
and I think there's another side effect
going to why there's so much love here
when you have people with regardless of
what they look like superficially or
where they come from or what type of a
background they come from but they all
have that same core desire to understand
the universe they all have that same
core desire to push Humanity forward and
you bring them all together into a
community like this and then you push
them in a frankly very intense
environment you cry together you laugh
together you procrastinate together you
you you you have sleepless nights
together you wander the Halls together
it creates the the deepest possible Bond
it's like people who who fought in wars
together they they have a shared
experience that that other people might
not understand or even comprehend
and because of that the rest of your
life
you will feel connected to other MIT
people and you will want to be around
them and you will seek them out and if
you're in kind of a mixed group of
people and you hear someone from not
from MIT start talking about how
impossible something is how hard
something is how difficult something is
you'll seek out the other MIT person in
the room and catch a glance and you'll
both share a little smirk
and while you're doing that smirk if
they are your preferred gender
you might see a certain twinkle in their
eye
and realize that you are irresistibly
attracted to them
so coming here it really does feel like
I've come come to a family a family that
I'm deeply connected a family that I
truly love
and I hope to just give you some
appreciation for the the potential that
that you guys are about to leave with
and when I said that 14 years ago at my
commencement you know it was kind of an
idea on paper but now I've seen what my
peers in my class above and below me
have done and it's really been nothing
short of of amazing and with that I want
to give you a sense of of internal
strength and and and happiness and not
just because I care about you and I want
you to be a happy person but because I
do believe that for you to really reach
your potential you really have to be
centered and and have a place to go when
when things get get a little bit tough
and you should take all of this with a
grain of salt I'm not a lot older than
than most of you I view me as your older
brother or cousin or whatever and and
and what I'm about to say these these
are things that I still try to live by
but I don't do I'm as at least as
imperfect as any of you guys but there
are things that when I am able to do it
I have found work work quite well
the first is is to just be as incredibly
and maybe delusionally positive as
possible it's a very cynical place out
there sometimes and that cynicism will
eat at your energy and will eat at your
potential and to fight it you should
smile with every every atom in your body
you should smile first thing in the
morning you should even force your this
is something that I actually do if I
have a I'm in a bad mood I actually
Force the smile it releases things in
your in your brain you should you should
smile with your mouth your eyes your
face your body at every living and
non-living thing that you see
you should recognize that the grass is
greener on your side of the fence and
even in the one percent chance that it's
not just convincing yourself that it's
Greener will be a self-fulfilling
prophecy
if you find yourself in your life in a
in an argument with someone whom you
respect whom you care deeply about
that's a time as well it's not an easy
thing to do but try to surrender your
ego to to the shared identity of the
relationship that you have with that
person
if possible do the exact opposite of
what your pride and ego Tell You In the
Heat of battle
and and if if you have the strength to
do it right when right when you're about
to try to give that last word and you're
about to say the kind of uh maybe
vindictive or below the belt thing just
pause don't do anything and try to just
give them a super mega hug
recognize that material loss or gain
will all have it but when you when it
happens be upset a little bit or be
happy a little bit but keep it all in
perspective they're all silly relative
to your the things that matter your
health and your relationships as much as
possible try to make people feel that
you're listening to them and and I have
a secret here the best way to make
people feel that you're listening to
them is to listen to them
when you're stressed and there will be
times of stress in your life
just look up at the night sky and
imagine the the Scale of the Universe
the age of the universe the distance to
the next star the the the the other
sentient creatures and other m-class
planets who are also looking at the
night sky and think about that shared
experiences the civilizations that have
coming by and it'll put your problems
into a little bit of perspective if you
can't take a walk through the woods
forget your name your identity your
Ambitions and just for a little bit for
a moment realize what you are just
another animal walking through words
another mammal and and recognize that
you don't you're not quite sure why
you're here but you enjoy the ride and
you love the mystery of everything
that's around you and you want to
explore it more
as much as possible and this is
something that's difficult and not
something that I do anywhere near
perfectly but I try is try to build true
empathy for for everyone and a thought
experiment that I often do to get me
into that frame of mind and it's just a
thought experiment regardless of your
actual spiritual beliefs imagine that
imagine that time isn't a one-way street
that you can go back in time et cetera
et cetera and and in your next life you
could be reincarnated you could go back
in time and be reincarnated as anyone
you could be you literally because of
that could be everybody in in this room
and with that little mental framework in
place imagine that in your next life you
could be that person you could go back
in time and be that person that you're
having the conversation with right now
maybe that you're arguing with right now
or maybe the person that you're passing
judgment on right now and if that is the
case then in your next life you will
have to put up with the current
self-righteous version of yourself
and so I want to just bring it all
together with another thought experiment
that I like to that I like to do that
helps me at least Focus where I want to
put my energies
imagine yourself imagine yourself in in
50 years you're in your your early 70s
you're the kind of the the you're near
the end of your career and you hey yeah
well we're very good
we have a few we have a few models here
if you have trouble visualization
visualizing that
but imagine at that stage or you're on
your couch 2062
and uh you've just finished watching the
the State of the Union holograph by
President Kardashian
and you start to reflect on your life
you start to think of all of the
successes you've had career successes
family successes the great memories that
you've had
but then you also start to think about
the things that you wish you had done a
little bit different your regrets and
and I could imagine what they might be
You'll wish you spent more time with
your children you wish that you had
spent you told your spouse that you love
them more frequently You'll wish that
you had spent more time and told your
parents how much you appreciated them
before they passed away
and just while that's happening
a genie appears
and the genie says well I've been
listening in to your regrets you seem
like a good person
I'm willing to give you a second chance
if you are open to it
and so you say sure and the genie snaps
his fingers and you blink your eyes and
when you open your eyes you find
yourself right there right where you are
right now
June 8 2012 in Killian Court some crazy
guys giving a commencement speech
and you say oh my God I'm in my
20-something Fit pain-free Body again
I I I'm around my my my peers again this
genius was serious I have a second
chance I could have all the successes
all of the all of the adventures that I
had the first time around but now I can
optimize things now when I see my
classmates and I give them that hug at
commencement I can hug them a little bit
harder I can show them how much I care
about them now that I my parents are
back I can finally tell them how much I
appreciate them I can finally give them
more hugs more time I can do everything
better I can laugh more I can sing more
I can dance more I can be more of a
source of positivity for people around
me and Empower more people
and so here I am you're truly honored to
to be your your commencement speaker
just in awe of of the potential that's
here the potential from in this time
that we're in a time when when the
revolutions the positive revolutions are
not going to be caused by generals and
politicians they're going to be caused
by innovators like you and in this time
to see you the Wizards of tomorrow I'm
just excited by what you're going to do
with your second pass thank you
thank you